what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news March is a
special month because it contains one of
our favorite days pi day in honor of the
occasion we set out to break the world
record for the highest number of digits
calculated and we got there with
thirty-one point four trillion digits
but in all fairness we had one big
advantage Google compute engine with
built-in features like live migration we
could continue running the calculations
non-stop over the hundred and eighteen
days it took without any downtime for
infrastructure updates read about the
history behind algorithms that calculate
pi and what we had to do differently all
on the GCP blog speaking of March
Madness Google cloud has teamed up with
the NCAA again to bring big data to
basketball if you've been looking for an
edge in your bracket this year try out
this NCAA bigquery quick lab this lab
gets you hands-on with bigquery using a
huge data set of basketball statistics
and even gets you started building a
machine learning model capable of making
smart predictions like your friends
never could try it out for yourself and
improve your bracketology skills you may
have heard the recent news about
Google's console free game streaming
platform called stadia but even before
that the cloud was helping to reinvent
gaming read about how high availability
and rapidly scalable compute built into
GCP allowed multi plays breakout hit
apex legends to reach a whopping 50
million users and just under a month
thanks to google cloud platform and open
source services like a gonna sand open
match it's never been easier to host
games in the cloud so if you've got an
idea for the next great game learn how
our partners did it and let GCP help you
make your game a reality our Google
Doodle on March 20th celebrated Jay s
box 330 fourth birthday but it also
marked another special occasion the
first time AI was used in a Google
Doodle cocoa net the open source machine
learning model analyzed over 300 samples
of box compositions to accurately
recreate full pieces from only small
fragments check the story out to play
with a doodle and download the model to
make some music if you want to read more
about these announcements or see a full
list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you